for the marlins it's sandy alcatra
so six scoreless on opening day the
first marlins pitcher with six scoreless
and two hits or less on opening day
since josh beckett in 2005. that is
really a terrific start to what he hopes
is a big 20-21 paul goldschmidt nolan
aronado on deck marlins have three on
the left side of the infield as
goldschmidt offers at the first one
lifts it down the right field line
duvall coming over he will have enough
room to make the play
still learning the surroundings
down the lines as he'll uh obviously
being right tonight's played some left
in his new home ballpark add another
step or two there
marlon swing three to the left side
against arenado edmund goes swinging to
miss throwdown to second is not in time
a strikeout for sandy that's out number
two but edmund into scoring position
one and two
out to left center field coming over
martay and sandy works around the error
it was five years ago today john gant
made his major league debut
scoreless inning of relief against the
nationals he was a member of the atlanta
braves
and now he's in the rotation for st
louis cory dickerson first pitch
swinging laces to base hit into left
field so a really good start for the
marlins one pitch
and a base runner right to the stretch
after the lead off hit by dickerson here
is martay
a 2-1
to marty this one ripped into left and
off the glove of o'neal rounding second
heading to third dickerson pro
is a little late it gets by arenado here
comes dickerson and he will score
gant was backing up the plate
not backing up third
so he had to run over
to pick that one up
dickerson never really slowed down and
it's one nothing marlins that ball was
stung by marte oh it absolutely was hit
on a rope that's a two-seam fastball
that stays up in the zone martay all
over it continues to swing that hot bat
now the gold glover o'neal in left right
1-1 last year
got eaten up by this
it's off the glove now he gets it back
in what i love is that aggressive base
running from dickerson he didn't meander
to second base he got himself in
position to take the extra base that
allows him to score on the bad throw
great base running you love to see it
did everything right
continue to put pressure on the
cardinals and it turned it into a run
and the o2 pitch got him fast ball up
first strikeout for gan well here's
yadier molina with one out nobody on
about that 99 miles an hour beats molina
upstairs
second strikeout for sandy the o2 2l
pitch to o'neill swinging a miss
a little bit of a delay but uh it was
inevitable sandy strikes him out two k's
in the inning you got molina and o'neill
back to back he's fanned three in the
ball game
the bases are loaded with nobody out for
adam duvall
got him big strikeout for gant
his third tonight
that's uh kk's gig he did that a couple
times in spring training
that split figured fastball that vulcan
pitch
very hard to lay off of when he throws
it well because it comes out like a four
seamer brian anderson walked back in the
first inning
and this one popped up
infield fly catch made by paul de young
and two outs this could be a momentum
shifting inning for st louis there's
chisholm bases loaded now two away
and he struck him out bases loaded
nobody out and the marlins cannot score
as we go to the fourth paul goldschmidt
to lead it off
how about six strikeouts in a row for
sandy alcantara the circle change
back-to-back circle changes to
goldschmidt first one a little
higher in the strike zone for strike two
this
starting out of the strike zone
for strike three
another strikeout for sandy alcatra to
make it eight
there's a circle change working its way
down in the strike zone love it
now o'neill who struck out to end the
second well for the second time tonight
o'neal down on strikes and make it nine
for sandy alcantara one shy of a career
high well similar pitch to
personally speaking here with o'neill
the elevated fastball that's what he saw
his first time up that's what he struck
out on does it again that's good when
you've got pinpoint control and you're
throwing 98.
quick work of justin williams 10
strikeouts to match a career high for
sandy alcantara last time for jazz bases
loaded two outs now bases loaded one out
out to left field o'neal toward the line
rolls and makes the catch it'll be a sac
fly for jazz so close to a lot more but
the marlins will take their second run
well a good swing by jazz interestingly
enough yadi tried to do it to him again
he asked for a high fastball it was a
low fast ball
but jazz
was ready to hit the fastball regardless
lines it out to left it's a really nice
catch by o'neill
the gold glover from last season
[Applause]
it always feels good to come through
jazz a strikeout victim his first two
times up coming through with the bases
loaded
they're all loaded up for the cardinals
shortstop and cleanup hitter oh for two
tonight first pitch to de young
gets away here comes edmond he will
score in the runners advance
it's now a 2-1 game
what happened is alfaro tries to steal
that pitch it was a ball down he tries
to steal it up and unfortunately
sometimes
when you try to
pick that ball up
to get that strike that moving action
he missed the ball right off the edge of
his gloves
ground ball left side runners
initially stayed put now they scored
that is goldsmith he scores and that
ties it up at two
well what a great play by
an aggressively
not fast runner
he's taken all the chances in the world
right here to tie this game that
overhead was such a great shot watch
this he sees the ground ball he knows he
can't go he really wants to score
there's nothing you can do to get him
right there at third and he just goes
for it
and i believe it might be a really close
play if he doesn't second guess or
second clutch that double clutch that
ball
this is a great play by goldie
and molina on the first pitch hits a
high fly ball to starling marte plenty
deep
orinata will tag up and the cardinals
have their first lead of the night it's
3-2 st louis
and giovanni gallegos is into the game
26 pitches last night that was more than
he threw at any game last year so we'll
see how he bounces back
a strikeout
of cooper to start the ball game for
gallegos duvall one for three on the
night and a 2-2 pitch
got him looking for something else
back-to-back case for gallegos
seventh marlin to strike out tonight
did you say he was looking for something
else yeah not the fastball down the
middle
no
and he catches the outside corner
no problem strikes out the side so three
strikeouts looking for giovanna gallegos
in a perfect seventh round and round we
go until the bottom of the eighth tyler
webb is in he'll face chisholm here
that is gonna be fair down the line jazz
flying around first he is going to get
to second base
with a leadoff double
[Applause]
it's a fly ball
left center
and dylan carlson is there to make the
catch reyes gets the final out in the
eighth
don mattingly will call upon richard
bleyer numbers last season for the left
he started the year with baltimore came
over in a trade with the o's
cardinals will have dylan carlson
how about that stayed in just enough
didn't he goodbye it's a home run dylan
carlson his second
of 2021
gets out in a hurry and some some
insurance late here for the cardinals
and what we were talking about is
when you cheat just a tiny bit you're
going to leave yourself vulnerable to
everything middle away and anything hard
the pitches that you can hit are the
hanging sliders
paul deyoung did that the other day had
a conversation about it he got a little
quick with his hips and then the slider
was hung
and then the next thing you know he's a
little bit more locked in hopefully that
does the same thing for dylan carlson
alex reyes got the final out in the
eighth inning marty cooper duvall and
the final hope for miami the 2-2
he got him
the cardinals come back and win it the
final of four to two
and they've taken the first two
in this series against the marlins